[Musique]
bonsoir peu tes amis j'espère que vous
avez passé une bonne journée et que vous
avez bien manger votre soupe
moi j'ai bon j'ai toute ma soupe pas
trop très bien nounours tu sais que
lorsqu'on mange bien sa soupe en devient
grand très vite je sais patron regardez
comme je suis grand et fort je vais vite
voir si nicolas et pimprenelle ont eux
aussi manger leurs sous on l'échelle
prom pompon
bon bon soit vous avez fini de dîner
[Musique]
mais reste très bien nicolas tu que tu
vas devenir grand sa fille
mais bien sûr prenait la balle à manger
beaucoup
est-ce que je vais plus critique au
labour à plat c'est pas vrai nicolas
guinée il est plus petit nicolas attendu
on va vous mesurez trois maps ronald tu
te mets ici des toits du cola vient
tu te mets contre le dos de ta soeur là
et vous avez leur d'être de la triche
nicolas tu triches tu te mets sur la
pointe des pieds
allô allô les pieds à plat
nicolas je crois qu'il faut que tu
manges beaucoup de sous tu es plus petit
pas bonne elle tu sais pas mesurer notre
grand jeu ne sait pas mesurer
c'est ce que nous allons fera pas sont
de l'autre côté pas pr neil pam
cherchait à m oui allons nicolas mes
toiles n'a appuyé 3 voilà ma puis
viennent à nous mettre aux voix
merci ne bouge plus nicolas
attention je me joue pas sur la pointe
des pieds nicolas aux ânes on est bien
bon pas l'homme tu mesures à mettre sa
je suis grand je m'appuie et des drèches
bah tu mesures mais disent pas prenez
les plus grandes que toi bien sûr avec
ses cheveux fillol au loin de toute
façon nours elle n'est pas plus grande
que toi au loup et toi combien tu
mesures n'ose remettre à m soit 120 et
demi a durement g de l'asu oui je suis
grand et fort
et ben moi quand je serai grand je serai
grand comme toi et ben moi aussi bien
sûr les petits surtout si vous mangez
bien allons au dodo moi j'ai quelque
chose de très près ces acheteurs
qu'est ce que tu vas faire tous je veux
savoir combien mesure mon petit patron
willie plus grand toit voyons du col de
bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit des enfants patron patron je
mesure 1 mètre soixante neuf et demi un
mètre soixante neuf et demi
c'est formidable et vous la peine de
vous mesurer
uzak bien plus grand que moi patron
ollo roux bloor ce bonne nuit les
enfants embrasser bien fort votre papa
et votre maman allez vite vous coucher
et fait tout pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
[Musique]